Oh, my God.
Welcome to Scotland.
The home of malt scotch killed seven sea monsters.
It's time to get up close and personal with the Loch ness monster
affectionately known as NYSCI.
What species this sheep, what does she eat?
And how would life change if we found her,
this is what if,
and here's what would happen if the Loch ness monster were real,
the Lochness monster is said to be a giant Marine creature residing
in Loch ness. Scotland reports of Nassi go all the way back to
565 CE,
but she became an international sensation in 1934
when physician Robert,
Kenneth Wilson shot this iconic photo reported to
be about two and a half meters long,
messy is said to resemble a dragon or prehistoric monster
rumors even suggest that she's a,
plesiosaur a Marine reptile that went extinct around
65 and a half, million years ago.
So if Nessie really is swimming around the lock,
what kind of animal would we be dealing with? Well,
our bet isn't on some sort of prehistoric creature,
but a giant eel.
And if Nessie is a sort of giant deal, chances are,
she would be carnivorous.
This means she would consume the fish native to the Lake and any small
invertebrates she could get Nessie could chow down on pike,
trout, sticklebacks minnows, char,
and other creatures native to the Lake.
Maybe if she were big enough,
she would feed on some unlucky deer or otters that took a dip in the Lake.
But enough about the lock dwellers,
how would the discovery of the Lochness monster change human lives?
I mean, how would we even go about dealing with something like that?
Well,
we don't have to guess because the Scottish government has an official plan in
place in 2001,
the Scottish national heritage agency now called nature.
Scott prepared a code of practice.
If anyone were to find the creature specifically,
the document says that a DNA sample would be taken from the monster to
identify her once. And for all. Ooh,
I think going to experiment on poor Nessie, thankfully, no,
the code States that after taking the DNA sample Nessie will be released
back into the lock to sweeten the deal. Even more.
The document also describes that the species monster or not
would need to be protected from harm.
This is crucial because once it's confirmed that the Lochness monster
exists, curious searchers would be joined by hunters and poachers.
We can only imagine what a taxidermied Nessie would go for on the black market.
So how would a protected Messi repay the people of Scotland?
Well, the Lochness monster would undoubtedly become something of a golden goose.
The Lochness monster contributes almost 41 million British pounds
to the Scottish economy every year. If you could see the monster,
we could expect that figure to skyrocket the tourist industry and
Blockness would change dramatically.
Maybe there would be Lochness monster tours, just like whale-watching tours.
It's been pretty good since I opened up my hotel in Loch ness,
people come from all over the world to see the monster right from the balconies
trouble is S he's a bit shy and some days she doesn't show up.
So to avoid taking any chances, I invest my money in gold.
Gold can act as a hedge against inflation deflation.
And in this case, the state's fright of a giant sea monster.
It's literally the gold standard for value and can provide financial stability
during these uncertain times, just head on over to the sponsor of this video.
JM bullion.com.
JM bullion is an easy to use discreet accredited,
physical precious metals retailer with over $4 billion in revenue.
And over 2 million orders shipped JM bullion is one of the largest,
most respected online physical dealers of gold and silver in the world.
Get in touch with JM bullion.com today.
Even without evidence, the legend of Nessie brings the tourists in, in droves.
We are going to see a lock mess. I've done research,
and I know where to look for you. So they support hotels,
souvenir shops, and the local economy as a whole,
with a real messy in the lock. The economy would, boom.
The downside of that is all that attention may overwhelm the area.
And more importantly, it might overwhelm Nestle's ecosystem.
It's possible that the area would need to be restricted to a certain number of
people at a time, sort of like a Safari with humans,
not interacting or disturbing the animal.
So is it possible that Nessie may really be out there?
Maybe there's a chance of discovering a new
species. I mean,
there was a time when people thought the Platypus and Komodo dragon were the
stuff of legend. The good news is if Nessie is out there,
Scotland has her back,
but this has us thinking if Nessie is real,
that means some other big contenders are too.
Maybe it's time to look for the world's hide and seek champion.
What if big foot was real? Well,
obviously that's a story for another. What if.
[Inaudible].